foreign
cover the sky
your hometown is sieged by Massive
wildfires
you rush to escape unaware that behind
you the wind and the Heat have created a
monster a spinning Tower of flames
in a few moments it'll swallow
everything around it
including
you
what can a fire tornado lift
what will its blistering temperatures do
to you
and how could you possibly Escape one of
them
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were sucked into a fire
tornado
technically speaking a fire NATO isn't
really a tornado
tornadoes extend from thunderstorms so
their Vortex is in the sky
The Vortex of a fire tornado on the
other hand is formed by hot air on the
ground
to do this fire natos need an intense
source of heat like a fierce wildfire
the air warms up the surrounding Flames
begin to rise and a low pressure area
forms around it this causes even more
air to rush in and fill the void
this column of hell then starts to
rotate pulling in Embers Ash and flaming
hot gases
ta-da you've got yourself a fire tornado
not that it's any good news
sure they look epic but there's a long
list of reasons why they're nicknamed
fire devils
so how big and strong can a fire NATO be
fire tornadoes only last for about 20
minutes
they're also just a few meters wide
that's because height is more their
thing they can extend 10 to 50 meters
into the air
and the hotter the fire the stronger
they get
some wildfires have produced fire NATO's
over 1 000 meters tall
and their strength well they can have
wind speeds of over 193 kilometers per
hour all the way up to 240 kilometers
per hour
they've been seen lifting all-terrain
vehicles and a house with people still
in it
fire devils live short lives but they
all go out and one of these is about to
do some serious damage to your town
now you'd be facing a scorching tornado
taller than the tallest building in the
world
and for the 20 minutes that it'll be
around this fire devil will spark havoc
on the streets
around you roofs will be torn off houses
trees would be pulled out of the ground
and cars lifted from the pavement like
toys
you'd need to Duck and Cover because
smaller objects are now missiles darting
through the air
oh and whatever the hot winds haven't
snatched up could still burst into
flames
let's hope you don't live near a gas
station
things could also get quite dire
directly above you
this fire NATO could raise a colossal
plume of smoke five kilometers into the
air
if afterward you hear thunder it
wouldn't be your imagination
the intense heat could form a
pyrocumulonimbus cloud a thunderstorm
Cloud that can fuel The Firestorm with
dry lightning and by further spreading
the hot Embers
and guess what these are also known to
generate
yeah more fire nados
so what would be your best bet at
surviving
run like your life depends on it because
it does
or better yet find a car and put the
pedal to the metal
don't even think about hiding in a
basement unless you want to end up
trapped inside a burning building
flying would also be dangerous The
Firestorm could cause risky turbulence
whatever you choose you better do it
fast a fire tornado can be especially
dangerous because of how unpredictable
it can be it could turn and change
directions at any second
fail to escape and suddenly you'd be
lifted off the ground and sucks straight
into its fiery belly here temperatures
can reach nearly 1100 degrees Celsius
well your skin triggers a pain response
at 44 degrees Celsius
exposing it to anything above 48 degrees
Celsius for just five minutes can result
in third degree burns
furiously spin at over 1100 degrees
Celsius for almost 20 minutes and the
Char will go beyond that
your muscles would be cooked Beyond well
done and your fat would Sizzle and
bubble
fire natives like them crispy
by the time the fire NATO pulls you up
to cooler air you would have experienced
sixth degree burns
yeah only your charred bones would enjoy
the relief of this Cool Breeze and your
blackened remains will hover for a
moment over Acres of scorched land and
structures
where hundreds of people have also Met
Your Fate
whoa that turned out a bit dark didn't
it
if you want to consider it an upside
well you're far more likely to run into
a traditional tornado rather than these
destructive Columns of Fire
on the other hand you also have better
odds of witnessing a tornado hitting a
hurricane
but that's a story
for another
what if